Speaker 1: The David Pakman Show is, of course,
made possible by viewers like you through our
membership program, listeners like you. You can
sign up at join Packman dot com. It's quick,
it's easy if you already have a membership.
You can also now gift memberships by checking
the box that says this is a gift. Funny enough,
as you sign up and then we will give your gift
subscription to someone on our waiting list.
Currently, 600 people waiting for membership,
so it's a beautiful number. Let's hear from some
people in the audience. We do these calls now via
Discord. You can find our discord at David Pakman
dot com slash discord. Why don't we start today?
This is interesting. Let's start with
Alicia from the Pharoh Islands. We've
never had a Pharaoh Islands caller before.
Aliya, you're on the air. What's going on?
No, boy. Aliya, don't let us down.
Aliya from the Faroe Islands, please
unmute and will be able to chat.
Well, that's a shame. That would have been
interesting. Let's go instead to Brian from
Phenix, Brian from Phenix. You're on
the air. Hi, David. Hey, how are you?
Speaker 2: I am doing amazing. I wanted to first
appreciate you flouting the pushback and sticking
with the an historic pronunciation. I think it's
Oh boy, I appreciate you're going going your own
way on that. All right, fair. I'm wondering
if you believe in the long term, it would be a
more beneficial, more progressive outcome
to remove the filibuster altogether
and sort of have the Senate answer to the voters
for whatever legislation is able to be passed
in a in a 50 50 Senate? Or if you think that
that would lead us in the opposite direction
in a in a less progressive direction.
Speaker 1: Good question. So I here's
my view on this. If I don't think about this
strategically, the filibuster doesn't make a lot
of sense to me. The filibuster fundamentally
seems anti-democratic, so if there were no
political considerations, I would say
let's get rid of the filibuster altogether.
In practical terms, I'm aware that if Democrats
completely nuke the filibuster, at some point
it'll come back to haunt Democrats. And part of
the reason why is that the Senate is fundamentally
anti-democratic. And what I mean by that is we
have 100 senators, no matter how many people live
in any particular state. That's the state has two
senators. And so there are senators that represent
millions and millions and millions of people
and their senators that represent, I mean,
I don't know what the Wyoming population is
now. I think it's like 700000. So like each
Wyoming senator in a sense, represents 350000
people, which gives disproportionate power
to low population states, which are typically
conservative. So I don't love the filibuster.
I think it doesn't make sense, and I would be
fine getting rid of it if we were to somehow fix
the anti-democratic nature of the Senate, which
doesn't seem like it's going to happen anytime
soon, because that's the way the system works.
Speaker 2: One semi follow up question very quick,
would you support adding states
for that in the form of like
splitting California or adding Puerto Rico?
Speaker 1: I am open to adding states, but it
would not be specifically for that reason. I think
that sometimes it would make sense. There's a lot
of people. I mean, I think Puerto Rico should
be a state if it wants to be. I think there are
a number of different arguments for splitting
up California, but for me, it's more about does
it make sense for economic reasons as it makes
sense for other reasons, not just as a political
strategy, although as a political strategy,
it would almost certainly help Democrats.
Awesome, thanks, David. My pleasure. That's
a that's a meaty phone call, I like it.